paul is a great shirt oh thank you very
much
man it's awesome so
is there a particular joy in subverting
the expectations of long time marvel
fans who you know
think that we might know exactly what's
coming next
uh yes no
no let me ask you've seen three episodes
yes three okay yeah uh it's only gonna
get
wilder and the the the
my hope for this show is that it brings
in a lot of new fans through the sort of
nostalgia
um of those shows but also
i think it's incredibly satisfying the
latter half of the
series really will
for for people who have been following
marvel
uh it really is gonna pack a big punch
and they will they will recognize that
world
and it will make them look at that world
in a whole new light suddenly and i am
uh i think for died in the wool
marvel fans it's gonna be a really uh
it's going to reveal a lot of stuff
about the future
that's very cool you know one thing i
wasn't actually expecting was
how much i enjoyed the way you guys paid
homage to all those old shows like
having been a fan of those
those old shows myself did you have a
favorite era
of sitcom that you played around in um
well i
you know there were many that are that
that i loved and there were also this
i i think that my answer is going to be
slightly leading because
um because there are there are
there are scenes that i can't talk about
episodes that i can't talk about in the
latter half of the
show that where for instance i get to
work with one of
uh an actor that i really admire and
that i've always wanted to work with
uh whose work i just really trust
implicitly and
and and uh we have this you know these
explosive
scenes and um
i just can't talk about them but i will
tell you that um
i do love being able to track it's
really interesting the way
you go from the warmth of
of a a a a show like the dick van dyke
show
to the sort of cool cynicism of modern
family or malcolm in the middle and you
can
track the sort of american century
through these these um
these sitcoms and it was really fun to
play all of them but my
favorites i suppose of the shows that
you have seen
was uh
the magic show oh nice visions
uh death was one of the most dramatic
moments in
in the film series how far back did you
know
that that wasn't the end of wanda and
vision's story
i didn't know that that wasn't the end i
thought that was the end of that or
could be the end of their story but
um my
contract was up and i got a phone call
from kevin
feige saying can you come and see me in
louis desposito
in the office and i went oh my god here
it comes i thought i was getting the can
i thought they were going to do it in a
really decent gentlemanly way and
said it to my face and so i was i you
know i i
i i remember walking into the office and
wanting to take away any of the bad feet
and she said look
guys it's been an incredible journey uh
uh no half feelings i loved doing this
and they went well
wait are you leaving and i went no are
you
are you firing me and they went no and i
went oh okay anyway
good because we want to talk about a tv
show and i went that's fantastic
yeah that's awesome well i'm like
you guys have left us all wanting so
much more it's going to be torture now
having to wait
until the fourth episode because we've
seen the first three already
so i mean i guess thank you for that
oh that's uh i'm sorry for the torture
but uh there will be
uh there will be um there will be
satisfaction
fantastic all right man thanks so much
for your time
you